foreign
season one finale of House of the Dragon
ended with a shocking death
possessiveness and his passion and love
and jealousy yeah and the fans well they
have a lot to say about it pretty
incredible lots of spoilers ahead you've
been warned after rainyra learned her
dad viserys died and aegon was crowned
king of Westeros without her knowledge
she and the black Council began the Mad
Dash to collect allies across the realm
rhaenyra is uh gosh she's a person she's
trying to figure out
where she slots in how to live in the
world how to live in the world
authentically
um where she slots in in terms of sort
of the Targaryen family simultaneously
she's a person who also feels
um kind of like an outsider within her
family unit and an outsider at court and
she feels to be at odds with how she's
read by the world and while all the men
around the council's painted table
wanted to head to war branera wasn't
here for it I do not wish to rule over a
kingdom of Ash and Bone my father's dead
and he chose me as his successor
to defend the realm not cast it headlong
into the enemy had declared war and
despite mourning the death of her dad a
miscarriage her throne being taken and
everyone betraying her renero was still
making decisions in the best interest of
the realm that is until the very end of
the episode when renira's son luceris
came face to face with aemond who never
forgave him for taking his eye when they
were kids no
I want you to put out your eye
it's payment for mine
one will serve
I would not blind you Luke hopped on his
Dragon to head back to Dragonstone
aemond trailed behind him on a stolen
dragon and just when Luke thought he was
in the clear
foreign
yeah that's shocking and heartbreaking
death had fans sprinting to Twitter to
weigh in one user writing Luke didn't
deserve that another sharing this
screenshot of Damon Targaryen tweeting
me watching his ass not controlling the
dragon he stole it manages to sort of
have some drama the episode ends with
renera learning about her son's death
[Music]
[Music]
and that Fierce look had fans writing
that everything she does after this is
warranted legitimate justifiable
I think this moves the goal posts for
suffering once you've lost both your
parents and you've lost a lover
maybe you think you know grief
and then I think what's so awful is that
losing Luke tells us she knows nothing
about grief and completely changes
her outlook on the world going forward
[Music]